This is the Financial News Network, I'm Stephanie Shyu.
Sbarro said that it is filing for Chapter 11 bankruptcy protection...
...as it looks for restructure on Monday.
The chain has suffered since consumers reduced spending in the recession.
It was also hurt due to the fact that many restaurant locations are in retail malls...
...where shoppers avoided during the economic downturn.
Sbarro's also hurt by debt that it took on when private equity firm MidOcean Partners bought it in January.
It has total assets of about 471 million dollars and about 486.6 million dollars in debt according to the bankruptcy filing.
For further updates on this story and more, stay tuned to the Financial News Network.
I'm Stephanie Shyu.